all right so you guys have asked me a
lot about two subjects the new
spider-man suit and Mortal Kombat
rebirth so let's talk about those first
of all the new Spidey suit and
personally I think it's awesome it looks
like the kind of suit that a kid with
five bucks in his bank account could
actually make like the old suit it was
screen accurate and I really liked it
but it looks like something that a bunch
of people who went to school to make a
suit like that would make it was
accurate and looked expensive
this probably cost just as much for the
studio to make but it looks like it
didn't like if you look at it the Spidey
symbol on the front is like the paint is
running is a little uneven
it looks really dark just ratty and kind
of tattered it's imperfect and in that
for this movie I think it is perfect and
there's actually a rumor that this is
like attempt one like it's not the final
suit that he makes but I personally hope
it is for what this movie supposedly
supposed to be this is a perfect
spider-man suit and check out his wrists
boom
web shooters I think either that or he's
sporting the watch like on the wrist how
some people wear it on both wrists yes
probably web shooters which is great cuz
the old movie didn't have web shooters
it was like part of his biology he's got
bit by the spider and now he makes webs
which I was always like I understand
kind of but why isn't he shooting webs
out his ass what the spider would do so
if they're going the web-shooter route
that's accurate lore bring on the web
shooters as for andrew garfield he looks
perfect as Peter Parker I'm a little
concerned cause it dudes like 28 and
when you breach the 30-year mark you
start looking 30 you're not gonna be a
30 year old and look 19 forever unless
you're Gary Coleman or Andy Milonakis
you're gonna start to look older so
that's my concern on that subject but
we'll see as for the suit and how Andrew
Garfield looks right now badass and the
next subject so if you remember Mortal
Kombat rebirth was that seven minutes
short film that a director made for a
studio to kind of prove that he can make
a Mortal Kombat movie and he made it
like really realistic like reptile had a
skin disease Baraka was eddie gordo from
Tekken so you either loved it or hated
it I personally loved it and now it's
been revealed that Mortal Kombat rebirth
will actually be about ten webisodes
yeah I'm not a webisode fan but I'll
take it cuz it look like it wasn't gonna
happen at all and I also think that if
the game sells well we might see more
Mortal Kombat Mortal Kombat rebirth
webisodes slash movies so 2011 will be
the year that Mortal Kombat comes back
so what do you guys think about this
Andrew Garfield's look as Peter Parker
the spider-man suit and Mortal Kombat
rebirth getting 10 online episodes
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more that's right click
right here see more right there
who knew shim